let me start by saying I can't wait to
finish the series I've seen the first
five there's a lot of WTF of but anyway
I'm curious how did this thing actually
happen with you connecting with night to
get this thing off the ground is it's
one of those kind of fortunate things
I'd had the scripts I had the first two
episodes written for a while not knowing
what to do with them not knowing who if
anyone would make this because it's
quite a twisted story and I'd worked
previously with the scape artists there
were producers of a pilot I'd had shot
and I gave them to them and said look
guys it's I want to work with you again
and I've got this and do what you can
with it and then I went off on another
job and Jason Blumenthal the producer
had was working in Philadelphia and met
with nine and started talking about what
if they could work together and the idea
of doing something in television and
Jason gave the scripts tonight and the
next day we were in business you know
night love what he read and was keen for
us to get it done together so it was one
of those things like most things in life
it's just things line up at the right
time and guy gee I'm curious so you have
the first two episodes how much in your
head do you know where it's all going
and how much are you sitting down with
night to like sort of flush out where
it's all gonna you know what I mean
yeah it's it's um it's an ideal kind of
situation because I work very
independently a lot of the times I like
to write and then rewrite and rewrite
where and so with night every episode
that we approached we talked about what
the idea is gonna be the execution and
where it's heading so there's always
been a long game and a long plan but we
concentrate very much one episode at a
time there's no we don't move forward
until we're both happy with the episode
we're on so it's a step by step progress
because new things come along all the
time with in an episode new ideas and
new thoughts that could impact down the
line so it's it's great as a writer
there's something very loose he's very
trusting you know he understands that
sometimes if I just want to chase an
idea I'll chase it down and when I'm
ready to talk when we're ready to sort
of get together and discuss execution
and next steps he's there and yeah it's
a working it's a working marriage
I had to look away from the screen
during the Eocene good
right exactly talk a little bit where
that came from
in terms of where did that thing come
from the yield was good actually that
came from that was an experience my life
when I was 17 years old I was in
catering college and one of the first
things they taught us was how to skin a
nail and it was horrifying you know and
it's one of those things we you just
don't get over seeing that it's a very
visual thing and for me within the show
it represented that notion of being dead
but not being dead you know this thing
where you it's effectively moving and
the nerves are still going but the brain
is dead and so yeah I mean shooting it
was very difficult we had to be very
careful that nothing was harmed and yeah
so it's quite a visible visual moment I
know now you know place in the arm was
pretty much sick after that oh she she
told me she threw up yeah to do that to
a vegetarian is cruel but I couldn't
change the scene I completely understand
one of the things that's really cool
about the series is that it's definitely
a slow burn you know talked a little bit
about working with Apple on this and was
there ever any you know did they ever
give notes were like you know you know
what I mean like the collaboration yeah
the apple of let us do pretty much tell
the story that we wanted to tell you
know they were encouraging from the
beginning when they bought this show
from us they had scripts and so they
knew the style they knew this sort of
the story we were telling and we had
pitched them the first season and so
they were they were relaxed and
confident I think also having night
involved and having his reputation
furthered the type of stories he
delivers I think they knew what they
were getting and they wanted to
encourage us to go for it and they did
that they step back and they let us work
which you know a lot of times in
television you could feel that there's
interference absolutely not in this
Apple could not have been more
encouraging of us and more behind us so
I'm curious
obviously nowadays everyone is looking
it's hard to pitch just one season of
anything when you guys first met with
Apple did you sort of give them a plan
of like well this is what it could be if
we went five years this is what it could
be if we go three years things like that
yeah I think we never
need specified to them at the time how
long we wanted it to go we're always
working we're gonna tell this story
until it's told you know and whether
that's two seasons or five seasons or
six it's hard to know until you really
get into the writing process to see how
far the story can go so yeah we I've
always had an end game in mind I think
the days of saying you know I've got to
have every story for five years
otherwise no network will buy I think
those days are gone you know I don't
think networks or broadcasters look for
that any longer I think they want to
invest in good storytelling they don't
what you do is when you're writing
season one you start to understand your
own show so much better and so you
realize what season two is gonna be
there's no point going in at the
beginning saying this is definitely
everything you've gotta have the freedom
to create within this space I've spoken
to a lot of writers and they all talked
about how the first season is a big
learning curve in terms of what you can
accomplish with your budget with your
time and you know you can take a lot of
what you learned in season one and apply
it to season two did you learn a lot in
making season one maybe like a lesson or
two that you would like to apply to a
season two I think the main thing that
I've written most of season one before
we cast the actors that we have and so
once you see them perform and once you
see the strengths that they deliver
within those characters you understand
better what to lean into so having now
watched them throughout the process
writing season two feels easier they
feel more real and more human because I
can attach faces to them I can I
understand their speech rhythms you know
it's obviously they're they're
performing the script but at the same
time you realize what works in your
script what works for them as an actor
did you guys have a lot of deleted
scenes and stuff or not at all
very very little I mean a lot of times
I've worked in television where in the
Edit you're moving stuff around in order
to make it work absolutely not it's
pretty much what I wrote is what we shot
them what we shot is on the screen it's
it's rare but it's it's reassuring when
it happens I was gonna say that's very
rare it is yeah I mean there's a few
lines that have been cut because when we
look to them that fell it didn't quite
fit or I didn't work it wasn't my best
dialogue but that's the only thing
scene by saying it's a lair one of the
things I like about Apple is when you
when you release everything at once it's
very hard to have a public conversation
because you don't know who's watched
what I like that Apple does it week to
week after the first three episodes can
you talk about your preference do you
like binging do you like the way like a
weekly release I you know what I kind of
changed in my life there are moments
when I just want to spend a weekend
watching TV and there are moments when I
want to wait for the next episode to
come along you know the anticipation of
what's going to happen next I think it's
alluring that's that's what television
was kind of created for you know
scripted television is here's a
cliffhanger you're gonna wait if if the
cliffhanger just is followed seconds
later by the next episode it's not
really a cliffhanger you're not hanging
long enough so I can see the logic
particularly in thrillers to pass things
out a little more and I think Apple have
got it right in that sense on that note
I need to stop I will just say can't
wait to finish the the show and have a
fantastic day